الله عليك
دمر بالكامل وتحول الى اكوام من الحطام
كغيره من البنى التحتيه في المدينه
خرسون حتى بعد الانسحاب فيما بدا سكان
المنطقه بادراك حجم الاضرار التي خلفتها
اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر من التواجد الروسي
على غرار سكان بلده سنترا حيث يستولى
الروس على السجن المحلي منذ بدايه الغزو
ليحوله الى قاعده لهم بعد ان حرروا سجناءه
اليكسي كان حارسا في هذا السجن
كان مخبز السجن في هذا المكان عندما جاءوا
الى هنا قالوا انهم لن يخربوا اي شيء
واعدوا بذلك لكنهم اخلفوا وعدهم
سهوله لا ادري ماذا كانوا يريدونه
نهب حتى الارضيات الخشبيه من جميع
الزنزانه
فرضت القيود على السكان في المنطقه طيله
السيطره الروسيه ومنع حتى من دفن موتاهم
في المقبره المحليه
كان بعض الجنود الروسي يحرصون على اطعام
السكان ولو بالتبنيات قليله لكن البعض
الاخر كان لا يتردد في اهانتهم
الينا جندي واخبرنا انه من دون باس بقى
لنا انه لم يعدبوكم بما فيه الكفايه هيا
ساركا من الوقت ستستغرقون لجري مسافه 100
متر
لكن نهايه الكابوس جاءت بدون استئذان
احد لكنها سحابهم جدا
خلفها مدرعات ودبابات عززت بها القوات
الاوكرانيه عتادها في معركتها ضد من كان
يمتلكها